is different for men and for women  so like a man cheating is like him  buying another girl house  where a woman cheating it's her it's her  sleeping with someone else yes so I  understand that men are biologically  different men I mean they're they're  wired to kind of sow their seed I  understand that it's not in their nature  to be monogamous but that doesn't mean  it's beneficial for them and their  family in society as a whole no I agree  with you I don't I don't condone  cheating but I just think it's like if  you find a one percent guy like it's  like okay I don't feel bad for NBA wives  that get cheated on what'd you think  yeah like you know what I mean so I  think the point is like if a guy has  like all of the things that women want  it's not likely that he's going to be  faithful